we said I told the judges go to hell
when he sentenced me to death because he
couldn't look me in the face why do you
think that's a mistake
because he decided to send me to
Huntington prison the hardest prison in
America what was he gonna do before that
I don't know but he made sure I went to
the place that they broke you see
Huntington was designed as the prison if
he raped another inmate they sent you
there it was the first shoe program in
America it was the first really what a
shoe program a special housing unit or
security housing unit level 5 Supermax
you know like Pelican Bay and uh your
punishment was that you weren't allowed
to speak in yourself and if you got
caught speaking in yourself they came in
with a nurse and they after they beat
you down she jabs you asked with
Thorazine and they knocked you out for a
week and you lost your mind so it was
horrible like I told you the first two
years of my sentence every day I kept my
mouth shut I didn't care what was done
around me or not you weren't allowed to
say a goddamn word and a meant it and
you know allowed to talk to other
inmates nothing I dare you to sing happy
birthday to yourself like I did I paid
for that one they [ __ ] me up Joe but I
don't care about that look I realized I
was in a race I had to kill off the
person that I was the person that I
initially was upon entering prison was a
deceitful lying coward but no fortitude
because no self respect resided within
me and in utter humbleness I took
everything that they did to me and I
paid for every window I broke everything
I stole real I told and then I started
to love myself I figured ain't get
nothing out of this but misery so I'm
going out like the dude I must stand up
and I must speak beautifully on the day
they execute me I'm a walk to that walk
man I'm a Judas I didn't kill a woman
but I damn sure ain't no coward
I'm gonna find out everything I can
about life and then imma face my death
I'm gonna do it was yada V man like I
had this beautiful beautiful speech
ready for him to I was gonna lay it out
and just be a piece because I realized
there was nothing else to do I couldn't
fight I couldn't argue it didn't matter
because God's in control my life and I
really believed that I had a choice
either be a bitter pill and get sucked
dry by all the misery around me or get
my [ __ ] right and start loving myself so
I taught myself how to speak and
overcome this aphasia that affected me
my whole life and I found out that I was
giving myself neuroplasticity healing
and I became very graceful and calm in
prison I was so serene and so powerful
how'd you find out you were giving
yourself neuroplasticity healing I found
that out from Robin Sharma Robin Sharma
is the foremost authority on speaking
about neuroplasticity healing and when
he found about what I speak about he
said I am the living embodiment of his
teachings that through grace and dignity
and kindness I've developed my own
charisma that carries me with confidence
and that is the description of what he
teaches professionals beginners everyone
to explain neuroplasticity for people
neuroplasticity is a reward system
within your brain where in your
interactions especially with other human
beings heals you so people who suffer
from PTSD people who have had trauma in
their lives can actually heal themselves
by being meticulously polite and I began
all of this when I was released my
mother sat me down and she said Nikki
listen to me for you to get out of
prison and not be an Iceman is a waste
of everyone's time every prayer every
time someone called me the mother of a
monster every time a woman spent my face
every thing that I went through is a
waste of time
for you not to be a nice man so I want
you to promise me one thing every day I
want you to go out say yes ma'am
yes sir and thank you because I want you
to show respect for who you are in that
way they hurt this family badly no
anything I ask
I didn't notice she handed me the tool
to healing because neuroplasticity is
the self contrived act of rewarding
yourself for being a nice person and my
gift over the last 14 years is that I
made myself so amazingly pliable and
gifted at helping others find the good
within them that's the reason I'm truly
here today the thing that I've been able
to accomplish through my writing and
through my efforts is to show people
that you take things personally in life
you'd be then a fool because what you've
done is you've taken all the hurts and
you've made them to justify reason why
you have to be an [ __ ] to somebody
whereas you keep forgetting that you've
been given a break over and over just to
be here man dude I've been shot stabbed
strangled run over by a car hung myself
in prison to drug overdoses and I had
accountable trying to murder me for two
solid years I know that I could fall at
any moment from my own hand but God
blessed me I believed so much in my
purpose in life that I won't kill myself
I won't give up and it's only because
I've been tested that I know that it has
to be for a reason